sda
sie liest
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute geht es ein leckeres
rezept von mir und zwar ist es hier
jetzt der zweite teil
ich mache himbeer brasilien mit weißer
schokolade und in meinem ersten teil
habe ich bereits meine vollmilch praline
vorgestellt mit lukas füllen und mit
einer kanal spülung und da könnt ihr auf
jeden fall mal vorbei schauen was da auf
ein tolles set gibt aber ich habe auch
bereits gesagt dass man alle körper auch
so in dieser packung einzeln kaufen kann
das sind 63 stück und genau für diese
pralinen hohlkörper habe ich mir jetzt
eine fruchtige füllung ausgedacht weil
ich einfach aufprall ihren mag die gerne
etwas fruchtiger sind und nicht nur
schokolade und für die sowohl körper
brauche ich jetzt folgende zutaten
ich habe hier 240 gramm türe also
einfach schokolade können da weiße
schokolade benutzen hier habe ich 30
gramm butter 25 gramm sahne und 120
gramm beeren die waren tief gefroren
die habe ich jetzt auftauchen lassen und
weil ich nicht möchte dass ich jetzt
hier kern ein stückchen mieterin habe
seit drücke ich meine hin beendet dem
löffel und streift sie dann durch das
meine kinder führe ist es hier in meinen
in einer schüssel und ich hab das jetzt
über ein heißes wasserbad gegeben ihr
seht es hier
ich lasse es aber gleich nicht kommen
also kurz rostock schalte ich den herrn
es gleich aus weil ich damit meine
kuvertüre tritt schmelzen will ihr könnt
es auch zum beispiel in der
küchenmaschine machen oder einfach in
der mikrowelle
ich stehe jetzt hier meine samen dazu
durch immer schön alles auskratzen dann
die butter und das schließt ich hier
drin jetzt erst mal und hier könnte man
natürlich auch andere früchte benutzen
wie zum beispiel heidelbeeren himbeeren
erdbeeren ganz egal was ich eben am
besten schmeckt und hier gebe ich jetzt
auch noch die schokolade mit dazu
und darin wird das ganze natürlich auch
cremiger und etwas fester und natürlich
kommt da es eben geschmack wer möchte
könnte hier jetzt die kür hinzufügen
egal was in städten kinder schnaps oder
likören amaretto ganz egal was ihr
möchtet so sieht jetzt die creme aus
durch die weiße schokolade wurde sie
natürlich etwas klingt und stieß will
ich mir jetzt in einen einweg
spritzbeutel wobei man die auch mehrfach
verwenden kann und jetzt verschließt
sich das hier mitten im krieg ihr können
daraus zum beispiel auf einfachen gummi
nehmen oder auch im knoten reinmachen
und so fließt dann eben hinten nichts
mehr raus und ich muss das jetzt aber
noch fünf minuten abkühlen lassen jetzt
ist noch bisher war die würden die
hohlkörper schmelzen und dann kann ich
die hohlkörper damit führen hier vorne
will jetzt einfach eine kleine spitze
abschließend nicht so groß und jetzt
kann ich damit die hohlkörper
einfach ganz toll machen aber oben genug
platz lassen damit wir die hohlkörper
mit der kuvertüre verschließen können
so sehen jetzt die pralinen aus ihr sehe
ich habe ein bisschen gekleckert
aber ich muss jetzt auch gar nicht
sauber machen um es euch die zeigen denn
die pralinen werden ja später sowieso
noch umhüllt mit weiße kuvertüre unter
zeigt dass eben wieder verdecken kann
und bei mir hat die füllung nicht ganz
ausgereicht für alle 63 auf meinem blog
hier sind ein paar frei auf meinem blog
werde ich euch ab die genaue
mengenangaben für genau 63 kapseln
reinschreiben die passieren muss jetzt
erst mal einen kühlschrank geben für
etwa eine stunde bis diese trüffel masse
etwas fester geworden ist und dann
können wir die pralinen verschließen und
dekorieren ich habe zwar etwas weiße
kuvertüre im wasserbad geschmolzen sei
weißer kuvertüre müsst ihr ganz arg
aufpassen dass das wasser nicht zu heiß
wird
denn sonst geht die kuvertüre ich habe
es jetzt nicht mehr aufkochen lassen
wird es war nicht leicht für etwa 50
grad ohne dich die kuvertüre aufgelöst
und kann meine pralinen damit
verschießen zum verschließen nehmen
jetzt einfach eine
ein löffel und lebe jetzt hier die kurve
rein
meine parallelen sind jetzt abgeholt und
ich hab's dir richtig schön verschlossen
und jetzt nämlich wie hier in einem text
schokolade also eine textprobe russland
könnte auch mit einweghandschuhen machen
uns nur kälter dann nehme ich die
praline und ohne sie in der hand herum
und jetzt können dass sie zum beispiel
in so kleine schokoraspeln selten
dann habt ihr hier diese optik oder er
nimmt die praline und gibt sie in die
kurve rein umhüllte mit der kuvertüre
abgibt sie ausbildete und wälzt sie
jetzt hin und her da hat sie so ein
bisschen diese trüffel optik und wer
möchte kann dann noch zum beispiel so
ein paar süße zimmer strömend übergeben
also da könnte einfach eure kreativität
wieder freien lauf lassen und sie
einfach in irgendetwas tendenzen oder
auch einfach so lassen also einfach in
schokolade umhüllt und einfach eure
pralinen dekorieren
ihr könnt sie auch zum beispiel in
kokosraspeln grenzen von 17 aus riesa
mit kleiner raffaello kugel auch richtig
zu sehen wie eine praline nicht aus die
sind auch richtig schön durch gekühlt
und weil ich jetzt verschenken weil ich
sie noch hübsch verpacken ich verpackte
jetzt in meinen kleinen geschenktüten
die gibt's bei mir im shop zu beraten
und so sind die pralinen dann auch etwas
außerhalb war im kühlschrank
aber ich glaube ich dass ich so lange
halten wie sie nämlich richtig lecker
durch diesen fruchtigen kern des
praktisch meine selbstgemachte
geschenkidee aus weißem schokolade
hohlkörper und dieses rezept gibt es auf
meinem blog auch sally blog.de die
ganzen produkte verlinke ich in meiner
infobox unter diesem video
die gibt's nämlich alle bei mir im shop
zu kaufen und ich hoffe dass euch das
rezept gefallen hat und freue mich auf
eure pralinen kreationen
ich freue mich schon aufs nächste mal
wieder des balles und am ende verlinkt
ich euch noch die anderen zwei rezepte